barring surfers from all around the
world are going to a chilly new surf
spot way up in the Arctic northern
Norway has 24-hour summer sunshine and
brutal blizzards in the winter well the
water temperature is barely above
freezing but dedicated surfers say the
Arctic provides a perfect wave and
spiritual experience Jonathan Vigliotti
went to the region to test the water
himself the islands of La footin inside
the Arctic Circle have been called some
of the most beautiful on earth so
fantastic
this Nordic terrain inspired Disney's
animated film frozen
[Music]
but it's also become an unlikely Eden
for the most adventurous
[Music]
battling frostbite and fierce currents
surfers ride waves as cold as 37 degrees
when I think of surfing I think of the
Beach Boys Hawaii not the Arctic Circle
I put the exact same thing back in the
day pro surfer shannon ainslie made the
seven thousand mile journey from south
africa well you came in you saw these
waves what went on in your mind at first
I was quite thrown away because there's
so many perfect waves in the loops and
islands with amazing mountains in the
background and like really good world
class ways and extreme weather very
intriguing Ainsley is experienced in
surviving the extreme seventeen years
ago he was attacked not by one but two
great white sharks near his home it was
the most amazing and scary moment of my
life today he joins an intrepid squad
who trekked here during the Arctic's
windswept summer and snow packed winter
Lapine's house when I get out the water
in the winter and my hair freezes on my
head my glance off reason of my
fingertips and it's quite painful but
it's quite a quite a cool experience
they are enticed in large part by this
man this morning we had to shovel out
the car
for about an hour before we could even
get out of the driveway California surf
photographer Chris Burkard is credited
with spreading the word about this polar
paradise sharing photos with his 2.8
million Instagram followers
the reactions range from everything you
could imagine it was like oh this is
this is fake this isn't real this is
photoshopped - like where is this I need
to go there what's it like to be out
here in the water I mean this isn't
Malibu this is in California this is the
Arctic well let's just say it requires
more of you you know it requires your
focus and your attention and your utmost
respect for the environment because
anytime you step in the water here you
have to realize that there's nothing
beyond the grueling work has paid off
his photos of the Northern Lights are
among his most liked and look outside
and it's Northern Lights are just
glowing and I was the only one here you
know and it was it was a really like
almost borderline spiritual experience
the region is capitalizing on others
seeking that spiritual experience in the
town of instead population 12 there are
two surf companies and it's not just the
professionals who are surfing here in
the Arctic more and more beginners are
writing this new way
wetsuits may help fight the cold but
they won't protect you from the waves
local Christian Breivik's been surfing
since 1988 and runs a local surf camp
when you first started surfing it was
one give or take a few yep that was in
the 80s now how many people show up here
to go surfing
among them American Aubrey Mabel the
ability say you always surfed in the
Arctic Circle like that's not something
that many people can say this place has
been transformed yeah I you know in many
ways I think it's a good thing a lot
it's it's this hard balance you always
have this balance of keeping places
sacred and wild and pure versus letting
people come and experience it and
letting them experience that joy
ultimately surfers like shannon ainslie
say the extreme elements will keep the
water clear do you worry about sharks in
these waters anything that bites up yeah
is the cold but not too worried about
that after all not even great whites are
crazy enough to swim in the Arctic for
CBS this morning Jonathan Vigliotti
laputan Norway it's absolutely beautiful
can you imagine though shoveling out
your car for an hour and a half then
going surfing
I'll go first no I don't care field trip
yeah too cold to quit Bravo to those who
do very very nicely done way to do it
where we all waiting to see Jonathan
getting on a surfboard
no Charlton Vigliotti yeah yeah just
wondering